ONE OF THE SURPRISE TO THE NET,S
SOMETHING THAT HE TALKED ABOUT
ALGUENTZEL STAYED WITH H  JUST
IT.
GOOD PLAY BY ZIBANEJAD.
OFF THE BOARD TO CRKREIDER.
PAST HIM.LER.
TROUBA STOPPED B BD GOT IT BACKO
CROSBY DROPS I I PANARIN.
THERE WAS A BIG CHANCE AROUND H
WIDE OPEN AND MALKIN FINDS
LETANG, WHER.
MOVES IN SAND A SAVE BY
SHESTERKIN AND
OH J, THE RANGERS MAKE A
LITTLE MOVE AND LOOK AT STROME
IN FRONT.
STROME HELPS BY GETTING INHE KA
BEAUTIFUL LITTLE BACKHAND PASS.
WHAT A PASS.GERS GET SOME
LL JUST
GET IT THAT'S BEEN SO
EFFECT YIVE.
THERE IS LAFRENIERE.
RANGERS AND THE RANGERS
HAVE EXPLODED FOR
BLOUEGER TAKEN DOWN
HE SCORES. AS HE
THROWS IT UP, I BELIEVE IT HITS
THE GLOVE